So, now that we know a little bit about
class variables, both the ones that we created and the
ones that come by default or predefined in Python classes,
I want to take a moment to talk about the
next big idea in object-oriented programming which is called
inheritance. Now, let's think about the meaning of this word
inheritance and how we use it in the English language.
You may have heard someone say that a child can
inherit some traits from their parents. Things like the last
name, the eye color, some money, if the kid is
lucky. So, if we were to take this meaning of
inheritance, like we commonly use it in the English language,
and turn it into code or model this in terms
of programming, we would create a class called Parent. Which
would have some attributes like last name and eye color.
And then we would make a class called class Child which
would inherit these two things from the class Parent.
Additionally, the class Child could have another variable of
its own called number of toys. Now, you may
notice that if we design code like this, we are
already beginning to reuse code, which is a huge
advantage of object oriented programming. Okay, so the next thing
we are going to do is take our design
and convert it into actual code. Let's do that next.